let's review what we've done this week
we've seen that the work done by a force
along a trajectory from point A to point
B can be written as the integral of the
dot product of that force with the
displacement going from point A to point
B well we note that this integral in
general must be evaluated over the
particular path taken from point A to
point B this is called a line integral
or a path integral and again I want to
emphasize the value of this integral
depends in general on the path taken
from point A to point B and you can
understand that if you consider the fact
that in general the force is a function
of position and so if you go along
different paths the dot product of the
force with a particular path may be
different even though you're going
between the same end points now the
reason that the work is a useful concept
is that it allows us to understand how
the kinetic energy of an object so the
kinetic energy is one-half MV squared
the work allows us to understand how the
kinetic energy evolves under the action
of the force and we see that through
what's called the work kinetic energy
theorem which states that the work done
so again the integral of F dot d s from
point A to point B evaluated along the
specific path is equal to the change in
the kinetic energy so that's one-half
and the B squared since B is the final
point minus one-half M VA squared where
a is the initial point and this is equal
to the change
in the kinetic energy and we derived
this theorem from Newton's second law F
equals MA so this is essentially just a
restatement of Newton's second law now
two things to note about the work and
this work integral the first is that the
work integral when evaluated can it just
gives a number right because the dot
product is a scalar and that number can
be either positive or negative or even
zero depending upon whether the velocity
increases decreases or stays the same
under the action of the force as you go
from point A to point B the second point
to emphasize is that again this integral
in general must be evaluated along the
specific path taken from point A to
point B which means that in order to
evaluate the integral we need to know
what that path is now if we have a
situation where we don't know in advance
what the path is then we can't evaluate
the integral so in a way it might seem
like a not very useful concept that we
haven't really made progress because we
need to know the answer about what the
trajectory is before we can calculate
the work done and it's not clear why
that's useful however what I want to
point out is that there are two special
cases that are particularly useful
the first special case is that of
constrained motion sometimes we know in
advance sometimes we know in advance
what the path is going to be because
it's because the motion is constrained
we know that it's going to be moving
along the other going to be moving along
a circular path or along some particular
track of some particular shape and as
long as we can describe that trajectory
we can evaluate our work integral along
that trajectory so that's a case where
even though the work is a path dependent
integral we know the path and so we can
evaluate the integral the second special
case we've seen is that there is a
special class of forces called
conservative forces and conservative
forces have the property that the work
integral is independent of the path so
for a work integral all that Matt sorry
for for a conservative force the work
integral only depends upon the endpoints
a and B and not upon the path you take
to get from A to B so for any path
you'll always get the same value of the
work integral if the force is
conservative and so those are the two
cases in which we can usefully apply
work and the work-energy theorem now in
general one might have a combination of
conservative and non-conservative forces
acting on a system and in that case we
can actually write the work as
consisting of two separate terms the
work done by conservative forces what
I'll write is w sze plus the work done
by the non-conservative forces WNC and
so the conservative work is just the
work integral evaluated for the
conservative forces
so f c for conservative force dot d s
going from a to b and because this force
is conservative
this integral is path independent let me
emphasize that here this is a path
independent integral it's not a line
integral it only depends upon the
endpoints because the force is
conservative the second term is the non
conservative work and that is the work
done by the non-conservative force F sub
n C dotted with D s between the same
endpoints a and B but this integral does
depend upon the specific path the path
matters for this term because there the
force is non conservative so in general
you can compute the work by separating
out the conservative force and the non
conservative force acting on the system
if both are acting if the force is only
conservative then you only have to worry
about the path independent integral
which in general is much simpler to
evaluate if the force is non
conservative then you need to specify
the path in order to evaluate the
integral again a path dependent integral
is often called a path integral or a
line integral